[Music]
just a few days ago the busy promo phase
of Mission Impossible dead reckoning
kicked off with the release of new
images from the film The movie is set to
hit theaters this summer and has a true
star-studded cast as the new images from
the official Twitter account
impressively prove one image for example
shows main character Ethan Hunt
strolling through Venice with his three
companions ilsefost Benji and Luther
another picture shows Tom Cruise in his
iconic pose raising both arms
protectively in an attempt to resolve an
obviously dicey situation in the
background you can see an armored
vehicle on its way to the scene just as
typical for Tom Cruise fans are scenes
in which the actor runs away from or
towards a great danger which is often
illustrated by running scenes that last
several minutes particularly interesting
is the look at the yet to be named
antagonist who was embodied by MCU star
Palm Clement TF there is speculation
that she will work against hunt and the
IMF at least in the beginning and
possibly later switch to the side of the
good guys there is also a snapshot of
Tom Cruise on a motorcycle receiving
instructions from director Christopher
McCary the motorcycle scene later leads
to one of the most spectacular stunts in
the film series as was already shown in
the teaser it's safe to assume that
we'll see a lot more Daredevil Maneuvers
in the upcoming Mission Impossible 7
dead reckoning part 1. a proper trailer
should be coming out soon given the
theatrical release date of July 14 2023
foreign
[Music]